hey
vsauce michael here and my tea is quite
hot
but it's not the hottest thing in the
universe
so what is i mean we know that there is
an absolute zero
but is there an absolute hot a point at
which something is so hot
it can't get any hotter well to find out
let's begin
with the human body your internal
temperature
is not constant 37 degrees 98.6
sure but those are averages your body's
internal temperature fluctuates by about
one degree fahrenheit
half a degree celsius throughout the day
in a cycle
assuming you sleep at night at 4 30 in
the morning
your body reaches its coolest natural
healthy temperature
and at 7 pm it reaches its highest
but a dangerous fever is not good
108 degrees fahrenheit is almost always
lethal the highest recorded air
temperature across
all of earth has happened four times in
death
valley where it has reached 120
degrees fahrenheit 180 degrees
fahrenheit is the recommended
temperature for water
when brewing coffee and at 210 degrees
fahrenheit
a cake is done 2
000 degrees fahrenheit is the
temperature of lava
fresh out of the ground but come on make
your
own lava like green science pro this guy
uses fresnel lenses to focus the sun's
energy onto
whatever he wants this is a small piece
of obsidian
volcanic glass which he can melt into
actual lava
right in his backyard keep in mind that
the sun is having that effect
even though it is 93 million miles away
from earth right up on the surface of
the sun is a different story the surface
clocks in at 10 000 degrees fahrenheit
but the center where fusion occurs is
ridiculous
temperatures there reach 28
million degrees fahrenheit which is also
known
as 15 million kelvin the kelvin scale
has units that are the same size as a
celsius degree
but it's an absolute scale where zero
is absolute zero when matter reaches
temperatures as high as those found in
the center of the sun
an enormous amount of energy is radiated
away if you were to heat only the head
of a pin
to the temperature of the center of the
sun it would kill
any person within 1 000 miles of it
speaking of which the energy emitted by
an object
often tells us a lot about the
temperature
of that object any object over absolute
zero
emits some form of electromagnetic
radiation
you and me we don't glow visibly but we
do emit
infrared light we can't see it but
infrared cameras
can wbd has great videos and here he is
hiding inside an opaque black trash bag
now we can't see him but his body is
infraredly
glowing through it if you want something
to be the right temperature to glow
in the visible spectrum you'll have to
reach the draper point
about 798 kelvin at this point
almost any object will begin to glow a
dim
red we can calculate the expected
wavelength of radiation coming off of an
object because of its temperature
and that wavelength gets smaller and
smaller
the hotter and hotter the object gets it
goes from
radio waves to microwaves up through
infrared to visible
all the way to x-rays and gamma rays
which are created in the middle of our
sun
at temperatures as hot as the sun matter
exists in a
fourth state not solid not liquid not
gas
but instead a state where the electrons
wander away
from the nuclei plasma if you've watched
my temperature lean back you know that
you can make plasma by
microwaving fire
but don't do it besides our sun isn't
even close to being the hottest thing in
the universe
i mean sure 15 million kelvin is pretty
incredible
but the peak temperature reached during
a thermonuclear explosion
is 350 million
kelvin which hardly counts because the
temperature is achieved
so briefly but inside the core of a star
eight times larger than our sun
on the last day of its life as it
collapses in on itself
you would reach a temperature of 3
billion kelvin or if you want to be cool
3 giga kelvin but let's get hotter
at 1 tera kelvin things get
weird remember that plasma we were
talking about that the sun is made of
well at one tera calvin the electrons
aren't the only thing that wander away
the hadrons themselves the protons and
neutrons in the nucleus
melt into quarks and gluons a sort of
soup but how hot is a tara calvin
frighteningly hot there's a star
named wr 104 about 8 000 light years
away from us
its mass is the equivalent of 25
of our suns and when it dies
when it collapses its internal
temperature will be so
great that the energy emitted the gamma
radiation it flings out into space
will be stronger than the entire amount
of energy our sun
will ever create in its entire lifetime
gamma-ray bursts are quite narrow so
earth is most likely safe
but what if it wasn't well when wr 104
collapses even though earth is 4702
trillion miles away
the energy it releases would still
be bad news exposure for 10 seconds
would mean losing
a quarter of earth's ozone layer
resulting in
mass extinction food chain depletion and
starvation
from 8 000 light years away
closer to home right here on earth in
switzerland
scientists have been able to smash
protons into nuclei
resulting in temperatures much larger
than one terra calvin
they've been able to reach the 2 to 13
exa kelvin range
but we are ok because those temperatures
last
for an incredibly brief moment and only
involve a
small number of particles
remember how we could calculate the
wavelength of the radiation emitted by
an object based on its temperature
well if an object were to reach a
temperature
of 1.41 times 10 to the 32
kelvin the radiation it would admit
would have a wavelength of 1.616
times 10 to the negative 26 nanometers
which is tiny
so tiny it actually has a special name
it is the plank distance which according
to quantum mechanics
is the shortest distance possible in our
universe
okay well what if we added even more
energy
wouldn't the wavelength get smaller it's
supposed to but yet it can't
this is where we've got a problem above
1.41 times 10 to the 32 kelvin the plank
temperature
our theories don't work the object would
become
hotter than temperature
it would be so hot that what it is would
not be considered a
temperature theoretically there is no
limit to the amount of energy we could
keep
adding into the system we just don't
know what would happen
if it got hotter than the plank
temperature
classically you could argue that that
much energy in one place would instantly
cause a black hole to form
and a black hole formed from energy has
a special name
a kugel blitz so basically what i'm
trying to say
is when you want to tell someone you
like that you think
they are hot so hot that not even
science can understand it
just call them a kugelblitz
finally here is something fun the sun
is about 4.7 billion years old about
halfway through its life cycle
and so far it has burned 100
earths worth of fuel which sounds like a
lot
but the sun is the size of 300
000 earths because of that discrepancy
you can have a lot of mathematical fun
comparing
your energy output to the sun's the sun
is way hotter than us and it puts out
way more energy than us
bad astronomy had a lot of fun with this
one and although it doesn't really mean
anything
it is technically true because of the
sun's enormous size
that one cubic centimeter of human puts
out more energy
than an average cubic centimeter
of the sun which should make you
feel quite warm inside